كسل وقلت نشاط نتجت عن سنتين قضاها طلاب
وموظفون يدرسون ويعملون عن بعض خلال جائحه
كورونا دراسه جديده خلصت الى ان العالم
اصبح اقل نشاطا منذ الوباء وان الاكثر
تاثرا هي فئه الشباب اي الذين تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 عاما وثلاثين عاما واضافت
بان النشاط البدني انخفض خلال الجائحه دون
ان يعود لمستواها الطبيعي بعدها وافق هذه
الدراسه يخطو الناس حوالي 600 خطوه يوميا
اقل من ما كان عليه قبل بدء الوباء في
الولايات المتحده مثلا الدراسه شملت ايضا
5500 شخص في الولايات المتحده وارتدى
المشاركون فيها اجهزه تتبع للنشاط اليومي
لعشر ساعات على الاقل يوميا هذا هو حذرت
الدراسه من ان استمرار الوضع على حاله قد
يزيد من مخاطر الاصابه بامراض القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه والسمنه وارتفاع ضغط
الدم والسكري وغيرها من الحالات المرتبطه
بقله الحركه
[موسيقى]